there's the extreme approach that you
are admittedly taking um and then
there's also just ordinary people that
might not be comfortable with the
language change and it just is awkward
and so they're afraid of not being
courteous or being accepting so there's
like these two things there's actually
combating and not being you don't like
transgender the idea of transgender
that's different than pronouns but then
just for most people it's just
feeling a little bit awkward and unsure
and not wanting to hurt or offend
somebody
well why is it important for educators
to teach about gender identity
gender presentation and pronouns why do
you think that's important because there
there is a difference there is
biological sex and a lot of times people
are conflating sex and gender so there's
biological sex and then there's gender
and that's a social construct in the
sense that
just because you're born biologically a
female doesn't mean you automatically
want to vacuum for instance which is
usually a feminine
activity or conflated that way
um and so it's this idea of giving
children uh in age-appropriate ways
an understanding that you can that these
things aren't set in stone gender
identity is not tied to biology you say
that gender is not set in stone
uh
what do you mean
i mean i mean that's just factually
incorrect uh saying that so you have
biology is the chromosomal makeup and
and reproductive organs and all of that
um and so that would be sort of the
nature side of things
but the nurture side of things is where
we see more of gender identities she
began by saying that my view is extreme
okay so the view that every single
person on earth has held up until 15
seconds ago is extreme and the view that
almost everyone does right now still
still holds extreme apparently according
to her but
there is this complete they are
conflating gender and sex because on one
hand they say well you got your
biological sex but then your gender is
whatever social construct but then they
turn around and say that trans women are
women
so a man who who identifies with the
with the gender the social construct of
womanhood actually is a woman so if you
can't you can laugh what you want but
you are this is a logical problem you
are conflating sex and gender just by
saying that so that's the problem
there's biological sex and then there is
gender identity part of me wants to ask
why you care so much uh because it's
really not that big of a deal oh yeah
um
i i loved it i'd love to answer that
question
i care about the truth so so basic truth
matters i want to live in a society
where people care about the truth and
we're grounded in truth um i care about
children
and this these insane ideas about gender
are being are being foist on kids
um and that that bothers me quite a bit
i care about the women who are having
their opportunities stolen from them i
care quite a bit yeah you are a champion
for